[Musik]
etwas gedacht und jetzt bekommen bei
myvideo
ja ich hab euch jetzt gut auf jeden fall
ist es mal wieder an der zeit ich habe
mich hingesetzt und ich habe mir gedacht
alex du musst auf jeden fall mal was
neues aufbauen so ein bisschen in die
richtung von wegen neues format oder
dann habe ich so ein bisschen hin und
her überlegt worauf hast du bock und ich
habe eigentlich sofort was gefunden und
zwar ich weiß selber es gab in letzter
zeit öfter einmal videos von mir wo es
zum essen ging das ding ist aber sowas
macht mir extrem viel spaß und ich
glaube dass gefeiert das auch immer und
ich bin jetzt gerade zum beispiel wieder
in köln und hier gibt es echt mega viele
verschiedene sachen die man essen kann
und auch alles von allem alle möglichen
fast-food-restaurants von a bis z keine
ahnung ja ihr habt sie wahrscheinlich am
titel auch schon gelesen und zwar
vergleichen wir heute von sämtlichen
fast food restaurants in ganz köln die
chicken nuggets wie gut findest du die
idee jubi ja ich weiß ich bin da
irgendwie drauf gekommen das war so eine
idee und irgendwie finde ich die gar
nicht so schlecht ich bin mal gespannt
was am besten schmeckt weil ich kann es
nicht sagen und jetzt war ich
wahrscheinlich was will alex da jetzt
als neues format haus machen ganz
einfach folgendes es gibt ja ganz viele
verschiedene sachen zuerst man kann eine
pizza essen pommes cheeseburgern und
irgendwann sieht man an so fällt aus wie
ich es war also erstmal muss ich wissen
ob wir darauf überhaupt deswegen würde
ich sagen weil 15.000 alex gibt es dann
die nächste folge ist denke ich eine
ganz neue zahl und dann sicher ob er
bock drauf habe und schreibt auch auf
jeden fall mal in die kommentare was ich
testen soll also seid kreativ es gibt ja
viele sachen die man essen kann das
ganze gibt's denn so ein mal wöchentlich
weil ich mein ich will jetzt auch nicht
jede woche so viel fast food essen ist
ja nicht so gut auch wenn ich schon eine
woche mcdonald's hinter mir habe aber
ich bin mega gespannt ich will gar nicht
lange lagern wir fahren sofort mal los
das ganze wieder so ein bisschen erstmal
im blog style und dann wird getestet ich
habe da bock drauf also
und ich habe mir schon genauen plan
überlegt damit das ganze nicht kalt wird
auf jeden fall gehst du jetzt einmal zu
mcdonald und casey und ich gehe zu
burger king und irgendeinem anderen
wichtigen wir müssen noch weiter runter
also ich gehe zum burger king und
irgendwo im laden den ich gar nicht
kenne jetzt mal aufgemacht wählten weil
das ganze darf natürlichkeit werden also
jetzt glauben schneller träumst du
mancher oder warum steht bei den hinten
grimms drauf was sind deine dreams at t
sowie dir überbrückt hallo also juli
geht es gleich zu kfc und zu immer auf
capes sie sieht man das von dem was sie
da ist capes die wie hin unternehmen des
mac ist und ich gehe dahin weil jetzt
ist grün und ich hole dann burger king
und gegen dicken schicken
also war das ist auf jeden fall wohl
einfach sechs verschicken also immer
dieses so ganz normaler weise müsse
jetzt ein parkplatz wenn man das chicken
ticken
diesen schicken klicken klicken sie dann
kann man hier kann ich auch schön parken
gestern habe ich auch hier geparkt da
kam so eine so eine wie nennt sich diese
loyalität politesse an und hat mir erst
mal schön straff zu geben und dann hat
es nämlich ganz blöde an gemacht als
sonst das 5 10 15 euro
so leute ich habe jetzt ganz fleißig
eingekauft wir haben jetzt drei
verschiedene insgesamt vier verschiedene
packungen die andere ist noch drin
juli habe ich irgendwo vergessen der
kann gleich und ja jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt
ich hoffe ja auch
ganz klar so heute herzlich willkommen
hier zum offiziellen alex wie chicken
nuggets test der beste fast food tester
auf ganz youtube wir haben hier jetzt
einmal macdonald dann haben wir hier
schicken schicken
dann haben wir hier fertig und natürlich
cathy und alles ist sogar nach plan
ich habe mir gut hinbekommt okay die
frage ist jetzt womit soll ich anfangen
ene mene miste es rappelt in der kiste
mini mac und du bist weg
ach so ich hab mir überlegt was überlegt
und zwar im haben wir hier jetzt
schicken alter
die haben 3099 gekostet das ganz schön
teuer und zwar wir wollen auch natürlich
ein gutes preis leistungsverhältnis
immer messen
deswegen und um das jetzt herausfinden
zu können berechne ich jetzt immer einem
wie teuer ein ticket ist damit man das
halt sagen messe oder versteh ich das
wahrscheinlich schon
die haben 390 kostet geteilt durch sechs
alter leute einer kostet 65 cent das ist
schon nicht wie ich ja dazu mal ganz
einfach hier saison
ich würde sagen netz co
also im großen und ganzen kann ich
eigentlich sagen war ganz lecker habe
ich jetzt auch nicht so mehr vom hocker
gehauen aber ja so eine art war ich
schon mal kurz was zu trinken werde ich
die kohle
damals schlug nur trainieren die nicht
so locker in die nächste klasse das ist
das mal so machen juli probiert auch mal
eben setzt man irgendwo mir macht rpr1
sachsen
ich bin noch alles probiert na dann
probier noch und was wird sozusagen von
0 bis 10 33 klassiert richtig schlecht
harry von wales schmecken ja allgemein
viel besser ticketing ist auch scheiße
ist man für etwas oder schon mal den
müll
er war kein mensch du hast nicht lange
444 so leute
king war schon mal ganz gut obwohl ich
nicht gut versöhnlich du hast viel
gesagt ich hab gesagt habe ich nicht
abläuft ich sag mal sieben dann haben
wir so ein durchschnittswert von
ungefähr 5,5 also genau getroffen
wir machen weiter mit chicken schicken
ich weiß gar nicht ob wir das kennt also
ist das eine kette oder meisters nicht
das ist außen gekehrte glocke nicht das
ist auf jeden fall einen nagel in köln
und das ist jetzt mal ein guter
vergleich finde ich zu so fast food
riesen natürlich ist auch in faster
sorgen aber ich bin mal gespannt und ich
habe mir bei chicken schicken mal die
currysauce dazu bestellt riecht
irgendwie ein bisschen nach sommer
grillsauce ich probiere es auch mal
hinter sich
also ich muss sagen es ist auf jeden
fall besser als berlin
und diese sollte gefällt mir auch juri
probierte viel besser als button ja viel
mehr was sagst du 110 6 0 6 0 6 wird
auch sagen wenn ich merke 7 gegeben hat
dann gibt es jetzt aber nachts immer ein
bisschen netter kritik ist wichtig so
leute wir machen weiter wir kommen jetzt
eigentlich zu unseren favoriten also
es sich zumindest am liebsten so was
also wenn ich es dann meister dann lässt
sich zumindest da sonst eigentlich kaum
verziehen
ich finde diese direkt schon viel besser
aus und guckt erst mal an so muss das
aussehen und nicht so irgendwie gelb
oder nicht ja wir haben hier natürlich
sauer
ich bin mal gespannt also ich sag mal so
wenn einer von denen jetzt die 10
verdient hat dann ist es ganz klar dass
wir haben darauf vergessen auszurechnen
virtuellen 14 voll ist für die chicken
chicken chicken nuggets habe ich 2009 90
bezahlt das heißt wir haben hier ein
stück wert von 49 cent wird aber nie
eigentlich also damit schon mal ganz
klar besser als burger king und hast du
eine rechnung die taliban ungefähr
also ich glaube bei mcdonald kosten die
drei euro 69 quittung dabei haben ihnen
klargemacht was aber auch nicht gesagt
in liquide und eigentlich müsste man
könnte mehr zulegen
okay doch ich habe es dann mal google
bei kfc kosten die auf 93 das heißt wir
haben hier auch wieder einen stückpreis
von fünf jahren 66 cent wie bei working
das hier wird meiner meinung nach nur
zehn du kannst
wie immer da hast du das alles hört
schon den abend essen willst du nicht
mal vielleicht danke sagen oder so
vielen dank aber guck mal die soße sich
auch schon viel besser und vergleicht
weil diese paradiese was ist lecker
ja da hast du recht aber es fühlt sich
auch schon viel besser was wirst du
sagen da haben wir endlich schon passen
sieger und ich glaube nicht dass die
chicken da gibt's von maeckes 1
naja ist ja auch kein tarif all schicken
da geht es ja um schicken die müssen ja
auch mutter in schicken chicken chips
didaktischen setzt auch die ganze
schicken ihnen haben und dann hat es
doch schon kassen das höchst gut sein
wird so unternehmens und ich will noch
ein essen von denen ich probiere ich mal
den hier mit der mango curry sowie heißt
nur das ding ist mit philipp mal sowas
auch mal komme es dazu
wer hat die besten kommen ist kann man
auch noch machen es gibt so viel wert
die besten pommes bleibt im westen
burger wird die beste pizza wer hat die
beste cola fast oder ganz ehrlich ich
und meine guten ideen okay leute und
kommen wir als letztes zu mcdonald hier
haben wir die ja dass hier sind die
chicken mcnuggets 6er packungen ohne
spaß habt ihr als kind geliebt immer
junior tüte apple 14 mangels pommes mit
ketchup und cola besten studierenden 33
69 geteilt durch sechs sind 61 cent
finde das ist schon krass oder so für so
ein kleines dringend 60 cent und der
produktion bis hin zu 0,6 sowie viele
tipps wie hier ist als auswahl haben
weil sie so leute ihr könnt ja auch
meine kommentare schreiben welches die
islam als abgesehen kiffern welches
süß-sauer findet ihr am besten an sich
ganz klar dass dann das und dann das das
ist beiden dass mac ist dass casey vier
so aus wie so abgestimmt
ok also ich würde sagen die kammer
planvoller nicht um christian aber
zweiter platz ich würde sagen so wieder
eine 7 aber ein bisschen besser ob ihr
dann seine acht ein bisschen besser als
bürger klingen also mcdonald s platz
nummer zwei kannst du ja auch noch kurz
testen wie trocken sind die mit ihr auch
trocken aber nicht von werken waren auch
trocken und die von dass da waren die
einzigen die nicht trocken sind wenn die
frisch sind vier wertvollen direkt 1,8
so sind die schon besser ich würde auch
sagen ich würde sagen 66
ich sage du bist aber nicht jeder
kritiker aber hallo lange kritiker so
weiter ja jetzt noch drei übrig unter
eigennamen nach oben gehen verloren
ja ich habe es ja am anfang schon gesagt
wenn ihr bock gehabt dass ich das noch
mache bei 15.000 mikes gibt's dann das
nächste format davon schreibt auf jeden
fall mal dass fastfood nahrungsmittel
oder wie auch immer man es
dann möchte in die kommentare was wir
testen sondern auf jeden fall x junioren
kanal vorbei ist in der video
beschreibung verlinkt und wir sehen uns
sagen morgen wie wir sind schon morgen
wieder am morgen 14 uhr gibt's neues
video haut reichen besonders die
schicken
trinken trinken